they turn to my left right now and I see
one of the gentlemen who's gonna be
spending eight and a half hours with me
and the rest of the NFL Network gang in
a Sunday game day morning edition from
the Superbowl on the NFL Network
three-time Super Bowl champion Willie
McGinest is here everybody rich before
you start menaces like you constantly
create the category I mean audience like
you just step it up every single year my
congrats to you guys for being you guys
are the first ever but this is the first
well I just wanna I just want to let you
know Willie I'm I'm a giver I share
myself you know what I mean like I just
I just want to make sure that if this is
big-time ya know if people want a piece
that they receive it you know what I'm
saying that's all I'm a man of the
people this you are you knew that very
very long time now I said this yesterday
when Brian Billy came by and remarked
how relaxed the Patriots seemed that I'm
hesitant to always look at the demeanor
of a team during media day and trying to
read into how that will come out in the
Super Bowl Sunday wash but it does look
to me and you sat down with TV 12 and
we're gonna see the fruits of your labor
on gameday morning on Sunday it does
seem to me that he's taking it in more
than he usually has and he realizes that
it's a ninth time sure but he doesn't
take it for granted doesn't how many
more times etc etc would you agree with
that assessment ly agree and I think the
voyage you know the destination is
always one thing but getting here is
another thing and I think players and
coaches understand that and appreciate
that that the grind all year long it's
like us working all year long to get to
this particular point the Super Bowl is
like the ultimate right if you can make
it here it's the best thing in the world
and then to go on and possibly win a
football game but it takes so much to
get here so hard to get here and to a
lot of other people's accounts a lot of
people didn't think that this team would
be here you know in a Super Bowl this
year so when you talked to Tom when I
talked to Tom he was relaxed but he was
really thankful of the opportunity and
he he did you know say that things are
gonna change next year whether
as guys retiring coaches leaving the the
roster changing new players coming in
things constantly change especially when
you win games so they they appreciate
the opportunity but they're excited to
be here but they're motivated and
they're ready for this game so Brady
told Jeff Darlington 0 he held up the 0
when he said this is right if he could
retire I totally believe that I think
that the concept of Belichick stepping
away potentially is nonsense not at all
what about Gronk do you think this is it
last one I think he could possibly could
be and I know he came out and said well
I'm gonna think about it for a couple
just doesn't want it to take up he does
anything right right and that happened
after you know a Super Bowl before he
says you know I'm thinking about
retiring and I think after going through
so much physically as a player mentally
and being in a grind especially in New
England like it's a grind they work hard
you contemplate retirement after you've
accomplished so much and done so much
and then you want to preserve your body
you know nobody goes above the waist on
that day no effort every time he gets
tackled I think that his legs are gonna
explode straight at the knees every time
the knees he understands that and I was
talking about that with James Jones and
some other receivers I was like what's
the worst thing you guys say once you
catch the ball when I'm not looking at
my leg is planted somebody comes from 10
to 15 yards out full-speed and they go
directly at my knees and you got to
think about you know your life after
football he's accomplished a lot he has
a great personality
I think he'll have a lot of
opportunities outside of football but I
mean he's been beat up you know he plays
in the trenches he's not like a safety
or a quarterback that rarely gets hit he
has contact every single play well the
McGinest here on the Rich Eisen show do
you really and we've had this
conversation on gameday morning and I'll
say to you do you really believe nobody
thought the Patriots yeah we article as
rich the only two people that raised
their hands was who was me and you we
heard a bunch of voices from a bunch of
different media outlets talk about how
the Patriots were done
not-not-not against the charges or kc
prior to that yes whenever we're playing
bad well when they lost to the jaguars
that was one thing Tennessee
Lyons right and then the Miami miracle
is something that never happens to do
well the numbers to everybody a lot of
people focus on numbers so when the
stats wasn't there the touchdowns wasn't
there when their drops were happening
when the penalties were happening on the
road like we watched the tape we see
what really goes on it was some bad
football being played and just to
remember everybody in the audience
specially Houston Texans fans if you
guys beat Philadelphia then the New
England is on the road as a wild-card
team and and the Texans have the second
seed so it wasn't picture-perfect how
things play it out no I know that that
that had Philadelphia not beaten Houston
- right - then then New England would
have just destroyed Indianapolis in the
wild-card weekend and then had to go to
Houston and destroy them before ruining
the Kansas City hopes you say anyway but
that's just the way succeed in having
the buys is a big deal it is and
obviously they every single time that
they've made the Superbowl it's from a
bi-week position so I understand all
that but when it all comes down to it
you know I it's still hard to believe
that the Patriots can make it seem like
we're the underdog and nobody
Expendables it - you iisten let me let
me let me rephrase this let me let me
give you a different pitch off for it
really okay when you've had so so much
success when you're in your third
consecutive Super Bowl which this team
is when you've been to nine Super Bowls
and you get to a point where this is the
expectations this is where you're
supposed to be I'm not saying it happens
all the time but it does happen with
players and personnel and coaches you
become a little complacent like this is
what's supposed to happen
sometimes it takes a spark whether it's
you playing bad football and people
calling you out which which was you know
what okay it was right you playing bad
people people call you out but there's
something that's super super powerful
about somebody telling you what you
cannot do and what you won't do and it's
over nobody decides that besides the
people in the uniforms and I think if
you needed a spark if you needed
something to get this guy going after
all the motivation he's already been
through starting with your Michigan
Wolverines when he played there because
drew Henson started about
right okay it started coming into the
league he's already carried a chip say
something about how bad they are how
they're done how they're over with you
don't do that to competitors so in a
quiet moment
Brady's saying that to you he was saying
that to herself and the rest of the team
he wasn't the only one in that locker
room and who's the best had taken all
the negative stuff and putting it all up
and letting the team just see it day in
and day out and reminding you of what
everybody thinks of you that's bill
that's bill now when did he Willie
McGinest here in the Richards or did he
ever do that for you absolutely that's
how I started think about when we played
in this game nobody gave us a shot in
hell to beat the Rams there was a
greatest show on turf we're a bunch of
unknown unnamed guys what was he saying
to you at the time he was saying we
didn't he didn't have to say it he just
collected all the information and kept
it in front of our face what are you
like how you were underdogs were a
14-point underdogs Madden said we'd be
losing by 30 at a halftime everybody
every single interview we did this whole
week which they're doing now wasn't
about us it was about the Rams and how
great they were and how we were gonna
stop them or like if we had a shot of
how we were gonna slow them down those
type of questions that saying like
basically you guys are just happy to be
here we know you're not going to win the
game but if you had if there's a chance
what can you possibly do to slow things
down so us that inferior rated us that
made us that would that had us angry we
had so much anger bottled up that entire
week of course we couldn't talk to media
and express that but but we have so much
anger bottled up that entire week right
we couldn't wait to explode on the field
we couldn't wait until the whistle blew
so we can go out there and just show
everybody you know what was really you
know was supposed to happen in shock the
world
so is it somebody's job and the Patriots
organization to collect all this
material on behalf of Belichick it
happens and deliver it to your app did
your to your locker room door slow it
first of all he sees it all in here's a
bill does absolutely how does he do that
because he's on the treadmill he's
watching the TVs he's listening to the
media outlets every single morning five
o'clock in the morning but whatever you
think he's with the articles come out
forget about the order do you think it's
issue of course he watches his show all
the time
oh hey Bill high bill FL everybody
saying hi Bill hi Bebel
we give you guys ready for the game but
I've been I've been on the Patriots all
your smart year long me look at you I
didn't take any cheese the only cheese I
did take and I think it was appropriate
was after the Miami miracle that that
sort of stuff doesn't happen we're
drunks back there and the football cards
sent through some miracle of pass to
pass the lateral football right to
Gronk's way that's correctable right and
no but the reason why I said that that
that wasn't like an indication of I foe
of how poorly the team was doing I think
it was an indication of how things
weren't suddenly going New England's way
all the time
right and I thought that that would
absolutely put them on a plane a couple
of times to have to make it through this
game at one time to Kansas City I really
thought that's just really the case no
that makes a lot of sense but in this
game you know we're not perfect and we
make mistakes in this show that bill
makes mistakes and the team the defense
makes mistaken the person was supposed
to have the guy out there for the last
play the jumper wasn't supposed to be
Gronk in that situation was supposed to
be somebody else
but you know nobody's perfect in his
game but if you have the ability to
recognize that yeah and self-correct and
make adjustments that's what's important
about a team and look it even for the
Rams I mean they couldn't stop the run
all year long they were playing bad it's
the second half of the season a lot of
people had the questions what's wrong
with Jared golf when they fell and lost
a couple of games everybody started to
panic but if you understand this team
and you watch tape and you see all the
things that were going wrong you say
itself you could self correct these
things you can make adjustments so what
are the what what does it all come down
to do you think what can you boy can you
boil Super Bowl 53 down to something
well I think in games like this some
time players try to do too much you know
I think they try to go above and beyond
I think it's important for players in
this game to it's not an ordinary game
but you have to play it as such you got
to do exactly what your assignment area
your job right and not try to do too
much the other thing is you can't give
up explosive plays in a game like this
you
- explosive offenses that can score at
will so defensively if I'm looking at it
we can't give up explosive place they're
going to make plays but we can't give up
a bunch of explosive plays and then I
think it's cliche but you talk about
beating yourself or self-inflicted
things that can cause you to lose games
the penalties the mental errors you know
the mistakes and crucial situations
turnovers all those all those things
play huge in the games like this and
then when the games on the line if it
comes down to two minutes you know or it
comes down to a field goal that needs to
be made by a kicker or you need that you
need a defensive stop whatever the case
may be you got it you got it you got to
step your game up in those situations
you got to play at a certain level Wade
Phillips have any it get it advantage do
you think and the fact that he's seen
obviously this team before coordinated
against it in the answer yeah it's just
game for Denver just you buying any of
that at all I don't because they changed
so much the Patriot hatred every day as
they change okay it's a different team
that he played in AFC Championship in
Denver when they beat the Patriots
handily in the defense you know they had
a phenomenal job but look Von Miller
DeMarcus werewolf
maleeh Jackson Talib like look you know
look the no-fly zone look what they had
and this defense is similar like they're
equally as talented but it's different
because the Patriots are gonna game plan
against you different now here's the
thing what's interesting in this matchup
Shaun McVeigh and Bill Belichick if you
got if you give these two men the same
exact things that they've seen a week
ago if they consistently see they're
gonna tear it apart so it's gonna be a
good chess match between the coaches and
the things that happen in adjustments
and the in-game adjustments that's going
to happen I'm excited to see how that
that's we've been talking about for much
today and certainly throughout the week
of all the storylines that's out there
McVeigh and Belichick obviously massage
versus right and Wade that's gonna be
what they call but what it all comes
down are you want to talk about who
executes the best I mean the greatest
executors of all time and
it's just we saw it a week ago again in
Casey two minutes to go he's like they
left too much time on the clock and Romo
was seeing what Brady was seeing too and
he sees it well doesn't he he does you
know I you know I I think you know deep
down Kurt would say and he could see it
just as well it just hurt does he just
doesn't say it I know Kurt knows you
know but he's done it so so but but you
know another time this year you really
haven't discussed a few minutes left
here with Willie McGinest it's after the
Pittsburgh loss as well did you hear
from your high school buddy snoop after
that yeah I did of course
what are you saying well Zeke Rowan know
he's on his second team his second team
is the Patriots he made it known he
called me called mr. Kraft and he's like
hey my my team is lost you know what my
other family is it's in New England and
being you know la guy got from Long
Beach in California he was riding around
success but he had to go back to his
original family outside of the Steelers
and that's the Patriots okay so hold on
a second I was asking if you heard if he
heard from you after the pate pit
Steelers beat the Patriots although as
he knows that that's there were still
lots more put along but now you're
saying know what I'm saying you're
saying look I understand you know
despite you being Long Beach Poly plant
with the double nickel at USC one of the
most vaunted numbers in all of college
football that you are a patriot now I
get it that anything that's going on for
Los Angeles on behalf of loss and loss
support there are support the ran until
all Sunday until kickoff so I don't you
know what the one thing I do is that
that is my family but and everybody's
like who you got the two weeks a week
ago who you got I'm like the one thing I
like to do is at least watch tape and
break things down and create and watch
the matchups and how things are gonna
play out yes sir and um I'm not like I
don't make my pick midweek or at the
beginning of the week I'll make it on
our show Sunday it's also a good cop out
where me asking you right now I'm going
to take your answer it is absolutely and
I'll see your cop out and raise you my
confidence that I've been using all week
what do you thinks gonna mean oh well my
preseason pick was Patriots losing to
the Rams so I got it 2-1
Wow thanks for watching Willie I mean
you're on the show
some guys switch saw switched up I have
Patriots Saints first and then after I
saw the Rams beat Dallas yeah I switched
my picture to a day I thought that the
Rams would we're going into New Orleans
and win nobody nobody believed me but I
took the RAM so we switched on our show
like when we did game day morning yes
when you say we you mean you
well me because you already had it right
from the beginning of the season and I
had the courage of my convictions stick
with it are you sticking with it now
though yes okay so you're taking the
Rams over the Patriots absolutely okay
well I'll have to break down any film
I'm just doing it just because I gotta
say I was right all along I got you I
got you not your jets that you you're I
definitely did not okay I did not
everybody knows but yeah oh no we talked
about it with say Kwan last hour when he
said that his dad was a jet fan he's got
a jet tattoo who was father for crying
out loud you know but you know I'm
thrilled with your guys Sam dharna being
the Jets guy yeah I am very very pleased
about that
need some help though okay so you're
saying snoop is throwing the Rams off
the bus and he's rooting for the
Patriots yeah when it comes down to the
Super Bowl if the Steelers are not in
it's always Patriots with him he's
actually with the Rams the Los Angeles
absolutely oh I didn't I didn't looking
snoop could do it everyone he might be
performing - is that right he's
especially out here but for the Super
Bowl though right doesn't he you know we
finished that up it's done like the
Teddy weddy Dioner did he like he's he's
on the he's on the board now so he
doesn't have a particular he stepped his
gaze on the bull he's running things
from the top that's not coaching anymore
he's on the Bo double discipline
chairman chairman good to see you Willy
great to see you I look forward to
hanging with you or an absurd amount of
time on Sunday eight and a half hours of
NFL gameday morning starting at 9:00
a.m. Eastern Time that's Willie the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience